i'd be willing to go in debt for a good
outfit you would yeah how much debt
however much the outfit costs halloween
is it another excuse to overspend on
stuff you don't need or is it all worth
it in the name of fun you know me i
don't care about your costume i care
about your roi or in this case your roc
your return on costume let's talk money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money all we talk is money all we talk
is money all we talk is money
all we try to who are you guys dressed
as we are dressed as sexy school girls
myself honestly i'm a pink ranger this
is amber from gentle impact
from business at least in wonderland
girl to rivia me i'm just my regular
self as a wrestler yo that's it man but
i just love entertaining people dante
from devil may cry ichigo kurosaki third
hollow form i am yoko littner from
gurren logon poison ivy miracle from my
hero my hero academia it's an anime and
how about you
i'm just a banana okay now when you're
not dressed like this what do you guys
do in real life for work i game and i
watch anime i work at a gamestop wow
gamestop you've had quite the year i
actually do princess parties i do no i
watch cartoons
as a job yeah it's my job nice man how's
that pay it it pays pretty well if i
told you it would give away my identity
so i couldn't tell you that and an actor
so
i screamed for a death metal band
wow
that was dope would you do one more
day trader for stocks and i you know do
my gym stuff and everything like that
guy get it
i'm a barista starbucks um i'm a
warehouse worker i'm actually a travel
volleyball player i work for a photo
studio i work at a dollar tree
unemployed i am a yoga meditation and
spiritual teacher
uh i'm an mma fighter
that banana will [ __ ] you up how much
would you say you spent on this outfit
we didn't spend anything
fifty
seventy eighty dollars at least fifty
two fifty on this what's that man four
thousand dollars 4k suit and everything
like that
no man go ahead bro you good you good
about 200 bucks thirty dollars oh like
thousands or a thousand dollars probably
like three four hundred dollars maybe 70
but um the bow i actually made myself
what's the most amount that you'd be
willing to spend on costumes probably
about 10k because i wanna do like a
mechanical suit and everything like that
you know you know those iron man suits
and everything there was one time i was
about to spend two thousand in the range
of like five hundred dollars a thousand
two hundred because it's a whole set of
armor with a blade
maybe
five hundred maybe a hundred bucks i
spend a lot of money probably not more
than like five hundred dollars five
hundred dollars i'd be willing to go in
debt for a good outfit you would yeah
how much debt however much the outfit
cost 250. 200 300 500. i have an answer
for that actually it was 150
100 or up um if it's really hot
and i'm really digging it then 200
if you guys had a financial superpower
to share with the people at home what
would you want them to know coupon save
those coupons in your gmail they work
will i invest it properties and stocks
give me all your money don't buy money
on stuff to make you cool do it buy
stuff that makes you happy spend all of
your money every week
don't don't save never ending money
budget your money budget your costumes
i'm gonna say uh save your money learn
how to stretch out your money charity
bless the people that brought you into
this world you know i mean make sure
that you can secure your future make
money disappear really fast you know
what i'm saying just swiping everyone
would have a plus credit free gas free
gas yes
is cash getting too expensive for you
yes it is never be scared of doing
the right thing if it's cheaper to buy a
maid cosplay do that any
change you find around any you know
loose pennies you find you know in that
you know culture on that sidewalk just
claim it save that money why is it
important for you guys to be at an event
like this today i always admire the
people that bring all their art well is
to give the people hope you know we're
just vibing we're chilling this is my
life i just love everything here so this
is what i live and breathe it's my soul
it's just a really fun experience to
just be at a lot of fun like being
dressed or watching everybody
wearing that amazing costumes it's
important to meet other people like you
and this is the perfect event to do that
if you like an anime you'll meet someone
else who loves that anime if you like a
comic someone else is going to love that
comic it's important because i get to
see other people's creativity allows me
to express myself it gives me a chance
to be free and i love
being a nerd and a cosplayer fictional
characters like it touches their hearts
it doesn't matter if you're rich or poor
man as long as you're with genuine good
people and you're having a very very
good time that's what matters to me to
get over some social anxieties that i've
had i was actually really really nervous
to come here and uh having so many
people ask for pictures and stuff like
that is such a cool feeling just enjoy
here have fun have a lot of fun here
yeah i get to be my inner school girl
and i love this where you are behind the
scenes and you're just kind of
manifesting now absolutely we get to be
out with people
that also enjoy the same stuff we like
and are interested in it seeing people
happy because i cosplay as a character
it's just the pride and joy of mine we
love comic books and superhero stuff
anime and all that to come out to see
everyone is basically the same as us
coming all in one together it commenced
now
so what do you think are you the type of
person who goes the diy route or spends
the big bucks on a baller costume only
you can decide if it's the right roc but
sometimes you can't put a price on fun
self-expression or meeting a sexy slice
of pizza save that money all we talk is
money all we talk is money all we talk
is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
all we talk is money
[Music]